i'm
ugly an independent researcher
i touched well for my analysis and i
found
out the error in my customer data
the same error exists published data set
i make this presentation or warning you
about
the basic error
i touch the mechanical vibration or
mother machine
this machine were used in
real space curl makers
worldwide my customer has a
very high knowledge about making a high
quality high precision machines
however they have poor knowledge about
digital measurement i was
exposed for designer site testing
under failure analysis at sony
corporation
over 15 years my failure analysis
was based on data analysis
that was very unique all these old days
i published several papers itc
international just
tested conformance but i
had not doubted about
measurement so i feel
there are big gaps between hardware guys
and
software guys
today's my talk is the sizing error
you can find out error
between two blood
top plots show the same
amplitude difference as
frequency this sizing
is easily simulated
by interpolation bottoms show
different amplitude
observed classified industry
audio light side
lower well for frequency waveform
obtained this encode
frequency higher than 92 frequency
this phenomenon went now and aliasing
many people many textbooks
describe however lower
than negative frequency exists arrow
i could not find out the literatures
describe this area so
class file middle very pretty
waveform a land of europe
i researched to her how to
get the error signatures
i'm making a small surprise module
dips dips extract the
error signatures and verified from
open data set at the time
i submit this talk i have no dips
so dips is still at the ground to make
deciding not complete
i will improve futures
i talk about improvement
not verified only discussion
why we talk about
digitizing camera yield
snapshot composed by a
pixel pure digital lady who analyzes
because time exists linking
snapshot over time so easily
accelerated by gpu
micro home transducer sensor
yield analog or signal
which matched compatible digital
via eddy converter today is my talk
adc has no error
this point roughly
only little application
directly use this digital data
almost all applications require
all future and extractive
the error exists between combination
of adc and
future extractor in my talk
digitizing include future extractor
i will show the model
to verify the yellow occurred
lower than the negative frequency three
fraction i will show you the first
second this is causing a systematic
error
the same arrow code has the same
condition
however sound
factor changed to a random arrow
basically no cigarette exists
randomizing a headlight so
only few ella cigarettes will
extract dips or
testing and they say it's a sampling
and the predefined interval
we call reverse over time interval
as a sampling light discussion about
uh frequency domain
as we understand predefined
interval fading or different
frequency 1.6
low case or very smooth
five jumping poles is not
measured distortion or gold
this aloe is the domestic
column
start time is not
fixed uncontrollable
this is causing a london hello
how do i guide this from the well-known
designer fighting to this problem
uh called correct skill
users suffered from g2
i should note repeatability
is a basic or principle
of the data analysis the same
data at the same condition must
be obtained
as you know error
depending on your frequency
look at this middle five
of something light
called max frequency
this frequency shows
the crazy behaviors
some start point no
signal detector shifting
small this triangle
more clear triangle
increase frequency only
point one changing to a beautiful
well-formed bad
different original feed or
waveforms low frequency observed
this phenomenon must be dejected
only down the physical system
lower the next frequency 7.1
uh smooths will form
5 distorted 1.6
means to no yellow so
maybe this is our boundary
or three and arrow
so next is a signal repeat number
bottom and the middle the same frequency
is
0.1 difference as the number of
peaks bottom no
frequency is obtained middle
original 7.1 is obtained
this is very similar to our amplitude
modification
that top is a pure
amplitude
smooth changes occurred
and the speculum the same
amplitude are retained cutting
frequency is a middle
however observed allowed
signatures indicate different spectrum
amplitude belt original frequency
can get
set as a start time
yellow card between measurement
and in a single measurement because
the reason is a l system
and adc system has an equivalent
track not locked
blue much towards early morning match
the blue waveform just
new green
small code more delay that midnight
led the waveform observed
i should note this is a frequency
independency so 1.6
well from little distortion
observed
so let's uh estimate a lower variation
caused by a startup time variation
simply white told only
three uh timing selected
they beat four six point
one tryouts three well form
of densely speculum normalized to
only one map
x delta original frequency and
observatory
spectral frequency difference
this change to a heat map rotate
this mere 6.1 kilohertz shows the
spectrum three cases
compared to other another frequency
heat map aligns toward horizontally
so we can check the
uh spectrum or observation
this is no arrow or only two
frequency shows and no alloys
the other cases
three fragments observed
uh this cases two
one but the different frequency observed
only two or ella signature
may be observed
and change to repeat number eight
difference from the previous
is this point 6.1
show the only one original
frequency however previous
shows sleep frequency
maybe this is a randomizing term
will form of them not become the
error signatures
so why 6.4 oh 7.1
as amplitude modification 6.4 is now
however it's a very magic signal
because different
repeat number different starting time
different waveform however
spectrum 6.4 that's very magic signal
summary depth shows the
two frequency is of error signatures
6.4 and 7.1
7.1 shows amplitude modulation waveforms
verification it's very easy to or
every testing however
independent me could not using hardware
so i challenge first modem for
published data set and i decide
the case with task 2 and the task 4
data set because task
two obtained by the only one only one
two
very unique kim a statistical
mathematical calculus approach on the
spectrum
task four force selected from
youtube which means non-controllable
measurement environment so some guy
television
handheld professional
equipment this money
mixed in one data set
this environment is the same as the
voice
recognization activities
analysis of this data set is very useful
let's start with task two
i upload the spectrum
of each of devices this
shows slide sample number
whole different device shows the same
peak 6.4 making
the slide i was surprised
why this pixel code
so they came back to american dips
7.1 as already now and the submitting
time
occurred two devices
that's important how to
get the angular signals
location time fft
no because different
way from shows same
spectrum no time information
i applied low pass filter bank
original frequency separated the bank or
you know then the burst fever
easily find out just zero
the time amplitude
6.4 through health example 1
this is a long name you can
get the original data from the home page
uh data name
example one spectrum
average six point four
this is a bandwidth frequency
first part low amplitude last part
high amplitude
zoom up and uh fft
obtain the same frequency
so point one same approaches for
this boat just powered
waveform shows amplitude modification
and frequency as much
change to our task force i
get the end point
our spectrum this is a subtle
name
holding forward uh
suffering sampled so fft shows
next frequency and no
data only rising point
about 7.5
97
for this data each indicates or
sampled by 16 and
up compatible another
typical case is so this end point
that exists next frequency
distributed just the at least
half of the next frequency indicate or
hello distorted
the same for 41 geo health
amplitude modification is exist
for cases frequency
repeat count is default
blue out
but the path time
count the peaks
three four three three three two three
fft 90.9
match the prediction
so i'm verified
this sizing error causing at lower than
the next frequency dips
is made succeed youtube
sound include this doesn't
let's talk about improvement
i guess
maximum required frequency
and allowable max error
which derived
by application policy not engineering
policy
error production and maximum error
set the required
sampling light which applies to our
measurement system f controllable it's
very easy
uncontrollable case i have no more
solution today i did not talk
this future extraction must be
derived to a waveform variation
where combination is needed to avoid
incoming web information
i only extracted fft
there's many many extraction exact
simple case or complex cases or
it's challengeable
and this is our architectural depth
depth of between waveform variation
but signal one
feed to extract obtained
features different platform
features summarized only one
indicator already
beyond fft and indicator
spectral frequency
it's challengeable to apply to other
future extraction
maybe your difficulty or a challengeable
item exhaust however i guess
this may be all important
to an uncontrollable system
may change your extraction
so it's challengeable the first
metric to relative error
or original frequency observed frequency
or relative or delta simplified
about uk have the
plus minus three percent okay
five percent seven k
indicates or about
nine or ten arrow exists
and many variations exist
next is absolute
foreign in this case
maybe no is no problem to a 3k
or distortion stealth okay
and or interesting thing is though
this creator space exactly are observed
to
our spectrum
for example three frequency
shows or 4.3 the only one
for advancing so continuous
uh singular change to uh
discrete or space it's very
interesting error
change how high higher than extra
advantage
causing lowering observation
and look at
near the next frequency of many
drops called only little
waveform differences spectrogram of
task 2 shows longer change
or frequencies
excess 80 kilohertz
expanding 9 more expanded right
cartesian or plotting along
this arrow affect
important frequency zone this must be
deject
hardware filter
important to avail from information as
the collectively
is nice or important signals
spectrum as poor indicators
simulation of blue light
small amplitude money or currency
land is a signal high
amplitude only one existence
so the nearly equal
amplitude let's think about
amplitude relation target frequency
amplitude
divided by your total or amplitude
its original fading original frequency
around
signals or band pass higher than
seven kilo health lead
ratio absolute ratio
several point very high
my point is a noisy high is
signal i think many
important oral signals exist over the
civil
health the best
cultural requirement it's a must
win reject frequency higher the next
frequency
approaches or in microphone
showing your down or characteristic
robust failure to this focusing
on the magistration
must to apply uh
adc's having enough uh sampling
light optionally uh deject
frequency higher than the max frequency
method microphone apply
digital low pass field after the disease
i'll not recommend right
lupus filter before adc is very easy way
that has a problem you must
check robust filter
showing a phase shift
this is a phase shift of drawing the
vertical
the frequency of plus minus shafting
further shift means the well-formed
variation
this characteristics depending on search
tax texture
circuit price and applied frequency
notice about audio recording
i think did not really allow something
light or split or this
frequency decided for all
standard launched 1982 very old
two years later pcit frequency
sex and mega health below
and the reason it's very changeable
making it just or consumer production
and human healing is poor
or high frequency so
not important at this old days
however professional standard
range to highest to about 200 kilohertz
10 times higher the human
sharing highest 20 acre health
and the microphone used in
handheld or pc is very cheap
electrolytical micro home can
get for up to a 22 health
it's 90 percent of our next advancing
touch about her year retracted curve
high frequency low this is the db not
lineal so many uh boss
defibrillation system applied to our
unique equalizer and
this is good to our uh
were not it's a challengeable
research conclusion
gabe's demonstrating error exists lower
than the
legislative and youtube sound
includes distortions that indicate
required or something related
which must be obtained
future error production and required
specification
check other recording or data analysis
of your requirement
finally thank you for the supporting
staff or
eks by data grover
because an independent researcher
may complete or based
on open data set and the conference gave
me
a chance to get to your questions
and comment